krischell has you blocked she won't
reveal why she blocked you do you know
why you're blocked I mean I have a well
hi Christine
hi Brice how's life treating you in
quarantine oh you know quarantine is fun
turning this ho into a housewife but you
know and I'm really happy great time
well when I feel like everyone and their
mother and their brother and their
friend and their high school friend they
haven't talked to in 10 years have
discovered selling sunset in quarantine
it blue oh yeah we were really fortunate
because you know we already had the show
wrapped and ready to go so it came out
at the perfect time because everyone's
home and you know they're discovering it
for the first time and I love it get
back to work but I'm not gonna lie
there's too many [ __ ] in this office
talk to me about kind of how the show
came to be because I noticed he's in one
curse words are bleeped there are some
blurs of stuff it feels like maybe it
wasn't made for Netflix originally well
originally we shot the pilot initially
for all networks because we didn't know
where it was gonna go so episode 1 is
actually the pilot that's why you'll
notice I have like 6 inches of group
really fun we didn't know who was gonna
go anywhere and originally you know they
wanted to go a more tame direction by
you know not using curse words and you
know staying away from certain things
and then they realize that people
actually loved it so then season 2 it
was like it's all I never like screw you
you know and it's just so much more real
it's more organic in my opinion because
we're not filtering ourselves and I love
that Netflix loves that side of us
people have labeled the show as fake but
I think there are just cinematic moments
but the drama we see unfold and the
moments we see unfold are your real
reactions in those moments those aren't
produced of course I'm a good actor but
I'm not back you originally moved to LA
to pursue modeling and acting right
yeah exactly this is this is a private
party this one's mine
what yes no I loved acting and modeling
but it got to a point where I was so
tired of you know being stereotyped for
the same role over and over and over I
was like I just want to give it a break
for a little while so I was like let me
you know get into a real job just see
how that goes and you know I was in real
estate for quite a while I've met Jason
through a friend of mine and you know
then when the show came up I was like
perfect this is great you know and I
love real estate because I can be my own
boss and that's the really fun element
of it and now I get to feed myself on TV
so I love it even more so there was no
trepidation about signing yourself up
for reality TV show you were like in it
from ii was off i think you know the one
girl that was like gung-ho all and other
girls you know they had reservations for
sure but for me i was the one that was
like guys we've got to do this that what
would you say is the biggest
misconception about you from the show
that is crazy one note raging [ __ ] all
the time
you understand the difference right or
do you still have dementia pristine but
that's what's fun for TV and i know
that's what people want to see so i love
bringing it but also you know there is a
sweet caring you know check me one side
to me and i do get my feelings hurt and
i I do cry and I am a big teddy bear so
I encourage people to get to know me
outside of the show as well.you in like
kind of the spirit of an Erica Jane
figure bring a lot of glam to this show
and a vibe to this show were you always
bringing the fashion at that level or
was that a conscious choice and you're
like I'm gonna be on TV I got a stamp
without no I mean I've always been so
extra so over the top
I've always been extra that's just who I
am you know so I was just being myself
and I love that people you know relate
me and Erica Jane that's obviously an
honor but it's just I'm just being
myself
it's expensive tipping okay so the glam
routine didn't change but did the budget
change when you're like I'm gonna be on
TV like how much are we spending to look
this good on time one you know it only
got better right guys I don't know some
call it fraud I call it love whatever
you give me a price point of how much
you've ever spent on glam like the most
you've ever spent
um well my glam everyday if I do hair
and makeup is close to $1,000 a day
damn yeah you got that love credit so
wardrobe either so you know that's a
whole other it's a whole other realm
this is the winner oh my gosh all of
your parties are see you I want to dig
into some of the drama of the show will
start at season two and work our way
forward what exactly changed between you
and Mary between seasons one and season
two I'm I'm just done talking I can't
trust you you disrespected me you
weren't loyal to me oh I feel like you
weren't loyal to me after we stopped
filming you know the cameras went down
and phones worked both ways and I wasn't
getting calls from her and she wasn't
reaching out and you know she was going
out of her way to make her relationship
with Michele really ugly and it was
something that kind of hurt my feelings
so when he went into season two you know
I hadn't talked to her in probably six
months seven months you know so there
was a lot of you know miscommunication
going on so it just kept building and
building until finally you know I was
like okay like let's let this stuff go
let's please let's just be friends so at
her wedding you know that
when I was like let's just let
everything go but then you know a man's
it makes it difficult I do want to be
friends with Mary and she's kind of
always like that body guard blocking her
and she want to make sure I don't get to
her so it's difficult it's like you know
trying to get to the president United
States hard but safe to say kind of
introducing the show into your lives
change the dynamic between the two of
you 100% I mean I'd be lying if it
didn't bleed over and say that isn't
bleed over into our personal
relationships I mean absolutely you know
since the cameras went on our
relationships have not been the same you
became kind of a breakout star from the
first season you have one of the largest
followings out of the cast do you think
that has any of that has affected that a
dynamic at all I mean I really hope not
you know for me and I'm happy I'm so
happy when people are successful so I
know for me it has an affected me but
you know maybe other people have fun
EKOS and you know I could definitely see
that happening but I would certainly
hope that it shouldn't change any of us
have you had to pick him it came down to
it who would you pick Davina or Mary duh
Nina that's kind of sad to hear that
things have changed that much it is sad
to hear and I was you know on my fin
stuff watching Mary's Instagram live and
you know it was it was fab to hear her
talk about she's like would you bring on
an island and she like you know didn't
want to bring me on the island and that
was like so it's just it kind of sucks
but I mean it is what it is you know I
always said like we were something that
we needed for each other at that moment
any time and we just aren't and we've
grown apart and we're so different
and I think it's a valuable lesson to
learn that you know people are always
going to be in your life forever and
sometimes you just gotta let people go
well you and Mary have kind of parted
ways you and Heather I've come together
because I'm one of the season one
episodes you like straight up tell her
to her face like I don't like you but
like I don't have to be your friend like
see what's going on and realize that
I'm just on it I'm just being honest I
say it all this stuff that other people
wish that they could you know her and I
have grown so close because you know
we're able to have these little
arguments Heather stop be a little [ __ ]
right now
stop me a little [ __ ] but they don't
need anything and then you know we get
back to work on a lot of the other girls
are like that mean a man's are like that
as well we have fights I'm like that was
stupid I can't believe we did that
anyway it seems to to people you don't
have that relationship with our Mary and
krischell Wow those girls really really
hold grudges do you hope for getting to
that place with them or is it just kind
of it is what it is I mean yeah of
course of course I have both I mean I
want to reconnect with the girls and
honestly it's just it's getting tiring
you know Maya's exhausted Davina's
exhausted Amanda's exhausted of her
shell just constantly just like hating
me so it's time to just move on and
forgive and I hope that you know next
season we can really see that because
I'm ready I've been ready it's just been
really difficult for those two when you
say next season you're talking about a
fourth season right not the third one
that we haven't yet seen I mean if there
is well it's been in the show has been
in the top 10 trending I think since it
came back so I feel like season 4s guys
this Finster
are you finished to stalking your
co-stars a lot are you lurking yeah well
because krischell has very publicly said
in about every interview she's done that
she has you blocked and she won't reveal
why she blocked you do you know why
you're blocked I mean I have a I have a
inkling mine blocked yeah yeah well she
says I have receipts that she knows
about that she doesn't want me to reveal
it's nothing bad it's nothing bad I need
I was I didn't like her at the time
I was I was being funny and I was
hurting certain comments okay it's not a
big deal it's just silly but you know I
think her and I have come you know I
think her and I have come from you know
we've come really far from Season one
you know she said in an interview the
other day she's like you know I would be
open to you know again being friends
with Christine so that was that was nice
to hear that she was open that's
something that I've always been open to
yeah okay I do think the show benefits
from the both of you being on it like I
think you're both necessary figures for
the show we watch and we love season
three looks like we're going to dip even
more into the personal lives than we
have seen and one and two because we're
gonna see you get married yes I know I'm
so excited
[Music]
why did you keep your relationship so
under wraps until after you were engaged
like you had taken such a big step and
nobody knew you know I like I'm not like
these other girls you know Heather's
very like oh I just met this guy and you
know like and she's writing her name in
cursive with his last name like I'm not
like that at all I'm kind of do like
died so for me I had done that before
where I invited you know people into the
group that I was dating for maybe a
month and then they would disappear and
it'd be embarrassing so you know I was
like kind of hesitant about telling
people because I wanted to see if it
went somewhere first and you know so we
were dating and you know it was like a
whirlwind and then we were traveling the
world and I really wasn't talking that
one and then you know I got engaged in
February and I wanted to wait to tell
people until I was back in my life until
I could sit down and you don't have a
one-on-one conversation with them you
know I really wanted it to be personal
so that's kind of why I waited it wasn't
like a big secret okay so your
co-workers just kind of blew it up into
something that oh you never intended it
to be cool and then there's some
misinformation it seems about how you
and your husband got together so clear
the air there well obviously you know
marry you know went out of her way to be
a little malicious for the television
show which is fine I don't mind she was
showing him properties I think he was
dating someone else at the time if
somebody cheats for you and that means
they don't cheat on what marry you know
that's not true so basically how I met
him was he went on a date with the
girlfriend of mine she didn't like it so
she said why don't you go on a date with
this guy if you don't like him fine he's
looking for a house just give it a go so
I said great so that got you know
muddled through the grapevine and - he's
a client he was dating someone else he
was in another relationship and like you
know it's good for TV but marry you know
the grill story she just wants to you
know stir some [ __ ] up so you know and
then krischell jumps in once a cheater
always a cheater kind of thing
yikes you know looking back now wait
guys guys guys guys guys
what is it that's all over the internet
right now Rochelle Stiles is dealing
with change her husband this is a star
Justin Hartley filed for divorce I want
to talk about what we're gonna see in
season three while we see your marriage
start we see the end of Chris shells
marriage talk to me kind of what we're
gonna see play out there with you guys
um nothing I mean he's not allowed to be
on the show so he's never been on the
show she's not allowed to talk about him
so you know she never really talks about
him so you're gonna see I think her just
finding out and because I don't think
there's ever any resolve which really
kind of sucks for her but yeah I mean
we're gonna see her try to keep it
together as all this is unfolding I
guess then happened just before your
wedding it was um
yeah exactly exactly it looks like she
storms out of your wedding
well my wedding was extremely hard for
her you know and that's really what it
comes down to is you know it was an
emotional thing that really was more
about her emotions at the wedding you
know kind of getting to her and being
out of a relationship there's really
nothing more to that but I think that
would be hard right yeah all right
something else in the first look at
season three is you meeting up with Maya
and Heather and seemingly proposing
leaving Oppenheim and starting your own
thing
I don't know testing male would you guys
ever consider living and then I noticed
on your Instagram you said you've
secured the bag and I are gonna become
your own boss and be a c e ho so are you
leaving worse what are you doing you
know it was something that we've always
talked about because we've always wanted
to be our own boss and the favoritism in
the office with Mary you know it's real
so you know it's really really hard for
us because we're all hard-working as
well so
it's something that's in the work so
I'll just say in addition to that you
know I'm working on a company for myself
as well so it's really really exciting I
just I think I'm tired of working for
someone whole time you know I could go
to like part-time but I don't like being
told what to do okay well you know the
show is focused around that group so
would that mean either we turn it into
kind of a real estate war situation
where we've got two brokerages going
after it
or don't mean you I would have to walk
away from the show well there's there's
been some drama going down and I feel
like I'm allowed because public
knowledge someone has left the brokerage
for good and started their own brokerage
so you guess who that is I'm guessing
Davina cuz she's a broker so there's
been you know a division going on so I
feel like you know it's kind of been
something that's happening for a while
and people are just trying to figure it
out before the chess pieces are going
right now let the game be okay so I work
I would imagine we're gonna see some of
that on season 3 yeah okay
should a fourth season happen what do
you hope that season looks like what
would you like to see this group evolve
to do I love to see this group evolved
to actually become friends and a family
again because it's so divided and it's
still broken and it's just not it's not
normal and it's not a fun situation
that's kind of my hope but I don't know
if that'll however happen is it I would
imagine this would be the time of year
you'd be gearing up to film again
normally we start filming in August
usually that's when we start you know
principle and that's coming up soon so I
don't I don't know if that's gonna
happen with everything that's going on
with the pandemic it might be pushed in
that [ __ ]
but could be this other company can you
give me any hints of what you're cooking
up kind of starting a lifestyle for a
bit you know centered around positivity
and confidence and you know includes
inclusivity and it's just okay so kind
of a place to showcase that part of
yourself you feel doesn't get shown on
selling sunset yeah okay what about for
your personal life are kids on the
horizon do you want to become a mom
definitely I definitely want to be a mom
I would love to have kids up and horizon
for me I just want to you know work on
my company and travel a little bit first
and then yes absolutely I would love
that
okay so maybe in a couple years down the
road what does your family make of you
living this very big life you know my
parents always knew I was gonna do
something big they loved they loved that
I wanted to be be my mom so funny she
was like you know my church group
watches this so if you could not talk
about your vagina that was sorry mom
whatever that it's great you know price
to pay
I've seen you say that you would love to
become a real housewife one day like let
this journey evolve into that you know
I'm a big fan of the show and it's
definitely crossed my mind as I'm like
okay there's gonna be a point where I'm
gonna be doing my own company and I'm
not gonna be doing real estate you know
the next few years so then what now it's
like it would be really fun to be a
housewife have you given any thought of
what a tagline might be I could say
something like I used to do real estate
but now I'm just keeping it real
Rob oh no pun intended Bravo all right
we've been talking for a while so I
gotta let you go but is there any teas
you want to give for season three I
think season three is gonna be really
fun
you know we see a wedding happen and we
see a relationship fall apart so you get
both ends of the spectrum and I hope you
guys love it and enjoy it's to see
[Music]